is raving about the pga stop at shadow  creek this past weekend  the golf course is one of the most  exclusive in the world and for many  players it was their first experience at  shadow creek  and another first the broadcast  promoting a betting app bet  mgm during the event that's certainly  the future of sports betting  so this is a quick prop bet put up by  bett mgm  who will win just this 18th hole between  these two guys it's just a really unique  opportunity we couldn't forego  and so for us to showcase the course  something we've had a great deal of  pride in the last 30 years  is just fantastic for us and so we're  just excited to be out here and hosting